habitué des terrains accidentés aux
quatre coins du monde Aurélien berger et
cette fois en Turquie le pompier
professionnel d'Amboise est parti il y a
une semaine pour secourir les victimes
du tremblement de terre une aventure
humanitaire et humaine qui l'a raconté à
Clémence dosc
à peine arrivé dans la région du seisme
Aurélien berger et son équipe ont de
suite été mobilisés ils ont réussi à
secourir une fillette de 10 ans à l'aide
d'une grue ainsi qu'une femme d'une
soixantaine d'années dans un autre
immeuble en moins d'une semaine les 36
volontaires du puits sont intervenus sur
20 chantiers le rythme est soutenu et
les températures glaciales
donc le temps de revenir sur le la base
faut compter deux heures de pause
restaurer de quoi se laver et après
dormir donc on dormait trois heures pour
après se relever pour se réchauffer
d'avoir partir sur zone donc en effet on
était 72 heures à faire ça une non-stop
donc ouais on a dû accumuler je dirais
allez on va dire à peine 24 heures de
sommeil sur une semaine de travail sur
le terrain des paysages de désolation et
d'innombrables victimes les pompiers ont
été sollicités par une famille pour
récupérer les corps d'un homme et d'un
nourrisson décédé sous les décombres on
a fait une promesse et on a tenu
concernant ce petit bébé parce que nous
avait demandé on leur disait que c'était
pas notre mission première et malgré
tout on reste encore une fois humain et
donc pour rendre cet enfant
au reste de la famille on l'a effectué
donc ça ça fait partie d'une mission
était importante pour nous ici on a pu
débriefer par notre médecin parce que ça
a été un peu compliqué quand on est
revenu sur la base les volontaires
devraient prendre le chemin du retour ce
mardi ou mercredi et atterrir en France
dans la foulée